Take Recorder records gameplay animation, live performances, and other sources directly
into Unreal Engine.
By recording and managing takes in Sequencer, you can achieve a highly iterative workflow.
Take Recorder is a valuable tool for recording actors' performances directly within the
engine, eliminating the need for external DCC, and it's especially useful when
multiple takes are required.
Live Link is a plugin that lets users stream animation data from external sources
directly into Unreal Engine.
It allows you to preview your performance work in real time.
Live Link Face allows for markerless facial performance capture using a mobile device
such as an iPhone to directly animate and record in engine.
Unreal VCam lets you create complex camera movements and effects through the use of
external devices, like smartphones or motion capture systems, to be directly applied to
a virtual camera in Unreal Engine.
VCam is widely used for pre-visualization film shots, virtual production where actors
can interact with the digital environment, and creating cinematic sequences, such as
in games.
One of the highly requested updates to Unreal VCam was to increase the functionality
on Android devices.
While VCam has been previously supported on Android devices, functionality was significantly
reduced compared to the iOS version.
The latest updates to Unreal VCam for Android have brought significant functionality
and quality of life.